بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله
وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
رياض الصالحين الحافظ النبوي
يقول وعن ابي هريره رضي الله عنه ان رجلا
قال للنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اوصني
قال لا تغضب
فردد مرارا قال لا تغضب اي فرد عليه
السؤال مرارا
قال اوصني قال لا تغضب فقال ثم ماذا اوصني
قال لا تغضب قال ثم ماذا
تغضب وهكذا فكرر
فردد مرارا
وفي كل يقول له النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
لا تغضب رواه البخاريed
[Silence]
‏is not
meent
are
and are controlling anger
here
very way the propet
worded this statement
because at
اسلوب مبالغه
this is
used people
will understand
this narration most of us are familiar
with this narration
tells us
ابي هريره
رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ang
time propل
‏So first of all this statement do not
become angry don't get angry
a very curious piece of advice don't get
angry why how is that possible is
possible for the human being to never
‏ang
second of all is this narration intend
in most obvious way meaning never become
angry for any reason
the first answer
is that when he says do not become angry
anger is not something that a person
necessarily contrs
when he does or does not become angry
‏contr is that willad
to anger
and
contring
ang
prop
‏to
become scared don't ever become
frightened this is something not
possible in obvious form person these
are natural emotions that a person has
and the human being is not in control of
his emotions in most instances
however what a person can control and
what's intended by the narration
‏is that a person is to control what
leads to his anchor and to avoid it.
‏If a person recognizes a situation as
something that traditionally makes him
angry or something that angers him or
something that may lead to anger, then
the person is to
is to avoid this thing and this go for
every prohibition in Islam
when
we are pribit from something we pribit
from anything that leads to
الله سبحانه وتعالى سيد ادم الحواء
ولا تقرب هذه الشجره
close
because eating from
close to
الله سبحانه وتعالى ولا تقربوا الزنا
تقربوازناز
اصول الفقه الوسيله
الوسيله
الوسائل
الوسائل لها العلماء يقولون في قاعده
فقهيه يكاد يكون متفق عليها بين العلماء
ان الوسائل
لها احكام المقاصد
الوسائل لها احكام المقاصد
that which leads to something has the
same ruling as it leads to
‏So for instance if drinking alcohol is
impermissible
then purchasing it is impermissible
selling it is impermissible carrying it
is impermissible storing it is
impermissible making it is impermissible
person couldn't say I just make it I
don't sell it I don't do anything with
it I just to make alcohol but I
don't drink it this is har why it has
the same ruling as drinking because
drinking
وصول
الفقه الذرائع
ما الفرق بين الذريعه والوسيله؟
يقول العلماء الوسيله تؤدي الى الغايه
مباشره
وهي مظنه وهي
تؤدي الى الغايه حتما
واما الذريعه
فهي مظنه
الاداء الى الوسائل التي تؤدي الى الغايه
الذريعه من الذراع كان الانسان يمد بذراع
لياخذ شيئا او ليلتمس شيئا
‏have
to
indly to those things are
why to safe
isit
therefore
one of the things that is pribit is
looking
at something which is haram observing
‏because
couldou
صلى الله عليه وسلم
eyes
‏and
commit and ising and comming
and
comming
right all things are
thingsad
to a
end
‏are just thatitم
and do not come close to this
we know for a fact that the reason they
were not allowed to come close to it is
because eating from it is what is pribit
why because when they came close to
‏private not only they into the fr and
consumed it
now their private parts became
revealed and
called them out on their disobedience
[Silence]
اجتب الاجتناب
اي ان تكون في جانب وهذا المحرم في جانب
اخر هذا هو الاجتناب والتجنب انا اتجنب
شيء اي اجعله على جنبي
هذا اشد اسلوب من مجرد التحريم والنهي
‏tyes
and
that a person is not only comm andit
somethingit
from comingose to that person is avoid
it
tells in the quران
that alol and ging isit
he
‏So avoid it completely
avoidance me I don't do it. I don't do
anything that leads to it and I don't do
anything might to it.
These are three things. ‏propet صلى الله
عليه وسلم says تغضب
entils that we are prohibited from that
which will take us or lead us directly
to anger such as
argument
or particular toics
or that which might lead us to anger
such as particular individuals for
instance that make us angry
ان شاء الله تعالى
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يضبط لنا غضبنا نساله تعالى ان يوفقنا
للقيام بامره
واجتناب نهيه انه ولي ذلك والقادر عليه
صلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد